SPEAKER: In this
video, we'll walk
through how to provide
your users the ability
to upgrade their subscriptions
and what that process looks
like behind the scenes.
If the user is trying
to access a feature that
requires a more
expensive subscription,
you'll want to have a
way for them to upgrade
their current subscription.
When your app starts, call Start
Connection in the Google Play
Billing Library.
Once the connection
is complete, you
will also need to call
Query Purchases in order
to handle existing purchases.
Make sure to override
on purchases updated
in order to handle any future
purchases that complete
while your app is open.
Each of your subscription
products has a unique SKU.
To change from one
product to another,
you just need the SKU for
the existing subscription
product and the SKU for the
new subscription product.
To perform an upgrade,
launch the Purchase
Flow with the Google
Play Billing Library
using the parameter set old SKU.
Replace the old SKU
with the upgrade SKU
by using the billing flow
params builder set old SKU
and set SKU.
Enter the new upgraded
SKU in the set SKU field,
and Google Play will take
care of any additional payment
needed.
It's important to note that you
can set the proration mode here
as well.
Check the documentation
for more information.
Google Play will send
you a new purchase token
through the Billing Library,
and that purchase token
will follow the
same steps outlined
in our video Understanding
Purchase Flow.
Your app registers the new
token with your back end servers
and sends it to the Google Play
Developer API for verification.
But there is one
important difference here
from first-time
subscription purchases.
This time, Google
Play Developer API
will return a linked
purchase token field
in the subscription response.
Be sure to invalidate the
token provided in the linked
purchase token to make sure
that the old token is not used
to get access to your services.
Your server will store
this updated information
and let the app know the
user's subscription has
been successfully upgraded.
You can follow the same
process to provide your users
with a subscription
downgrade option, which
you could make available in the
settings section of your app.
For more information,
visit the link onscreen,
or check out our other videos.